[Music]
so hi and welcome today I have a really
really cool presentation for you guys
it's really simple straightforward
easygoing so please relax enjoy and do
not do not touch your phone because I'm
going to get really angry now
my name is one and in a normal day from
9 to 5
they call me a software engineer big
data at Levu dating up in Germany and
there I spend my days detecting and
blocking spammers in the platform
however today I would like to remove
this title and I want you guys to call
me a data curious guy what's that well
because this presentation which is
titled why does my girlfriend is like my
music it's actually a fun project I did
on my free time this is something I did
on those days were the internet is down
or to go to Starbucks oh you have no
idea what to watch on Netflix also just
to make sure and just to be really clear
I would like to say that I am not
affiliated in any way we Spotify except
by the fact that I pay them 10 euros per
month now story time story time so one
day I was having a classy typical
Spotify on sunshield section with my
girlfriend when suddenly she look at me
she put her arm in my shoulder and she
came and she tells me and I quote your
music take is interesting sure yeah yeah
your playlist has a lot of variety
maybe intrumental ness Jesus really and
some of them are boring
whoa what girls sorry I was thinking
that night I went to bed really
frustrated like oh my god it's really
boring there was I need to find a way to
prove us she's from because you know
relationship are made of discussions and
it was like maybe I could use the power
of data and music to try to figure it
out if she's right or wrong and this my
friends is what I have for today this is
the agenda and next I'm going to give a
review of the pro yet the de era and the
audio feature that I use for this
experiment then I'll present to you my
attempt to prove that my girlfriend is
wrong in here I'll be
answering the question how instrumental
is my music how varied it is or how
boring is it then I'll move on to
supervised learning and here I did my
plan was to build a model able to
predict if a song belongs to my playlist
or her playlist and then I'll move on to
the other side of machine learning which
is also precise learning and here
Michael was to cluster my music and
trying to find similarities within each
of the cluster and lastly I'll present
some G's visualization because it's
always nice to take a look at the data
and then they happy ending now project
and data overview you know you guys know
how there's a lot of resources and blog
posts on the internet say in Python is
better or is buried blah blah blah both
of them see both of them pretty Python
and RP are now on the Python side I use
a package called Spotify which is the
one this kind of wrapper around the
Spotify API then I use scikit-learn
maybe you guys know what is it hey hey
and then hyper tools to present the low
dimensional representation of my dataset
and on the art side I use a lot of base
are to answer the three questions I
presented before I use a package called
cluster to cluster the data and ggplot2
to show the really nice plot that you
guys are going to see and of course
Spotify API which is the powerhouse of
this now my dataset is really really
small it is made of a thousand and
seventy four songs and with 573 like
half and half are from my playlist and
from her playlist now this older these
are the our saved songs I'm not sure if
you guys know our on Spotify next to
each zone there is some plus sign and
when you click on that this code to a
really big list called my songs and
these are our songs from that list now
which are the audio features were the
columns of the data set so Spotify
apiary has something called the audio
features which I have no idea how it
works I'm just gonna draw them I just
want it to thin like this is purified
they're really smart and this is really
correct so and these features they
represent characteristic of the Sun
starting from the first one it is
instrumental
and instrumentalists measure the present
of instrument in the song then we have
likeness unlikely see is the likelihood
that the song was recording in a live
setting then we have fishiness with
represent the present of words or speech
in the songs and then we have valence
which is how positive the Sun is or how
negative the Sun is then we have the
stability which represent the amount of
dance in the music then we have energy
which is a help energy how dynamic the
Sun is and then acoustic noise which is
the present of acoustic stuff now three
question let's start first once again
how instrumental is my playlist how
varied is it and how boring it is so now
the first one how instrumental is my
music so for doing this I simply
calculate the mean value of each of a
data features from my playlist and hers
and as you can see here right now first
on the first position is truly
instrumental bull she wins and then on
the last position species s means that I
have a lot of songs that are really
lalala instrument and less Berber
backward but on her side is quite the
opposite first you had a stability so I
mean I also have some stability
somewhere here because my Latin blood
but she had a stability and then she has
instrumental if the last one si si so
it's really like the opposite and here
we can see the the main difference so
here I am subtracting her values from my
values and we can see that on blue that
really tall blue bar is representation
so maintenance of my son the difference
from hers and on the other side is the
valence what they spin this means that
my sons are indeed more instrumental
however her sons are more positive so
maybe we could imply that my son son may
be more negative I have no idea but yeah
my parish is indeed really instrumental
next how very is my playlist so for
doing this I simply calculated the
standard deviation or if all the
features why because we know that a
standard deviation is a measure of
dispersity
and I wanted to know how far away from
the mean my values are so what does this
mean my intuition was that they if they
are really far from the mean that means
that the zones are really all
over the place for example here once
again instrumental Nessie the standard
is a high standard deviation meaning
that I have a lot of songs who are
either really instrumental or not so
instrumental and but however I want you
guys to take a look at the mean and the
song this is the important thing here
they mean in my case is point twenty
four and the song is to 1.7 however on
her side is less the mean is zero point
17 and the song is 1.21 so meaning that
according to the standard deviation if
we sum all of them mines are greater
meaning that I have more dispersity
on my playlist meaning that mine is more
varied last one how boring is my
playlist and you know boring and boring
is something is really subjective of
what is boring what is boring for me
might be really fun for you or really
shitty for you or really cool for you
so that was think like okay I need to
come up with something really nice and
cool so I decide like okay let's imagine
that one day I go to this party what
would be nice
what would be really awesome to listen
on that Perry and I thought well I want
really loud music because you're not
allowed to tune and tempo you know with
an eye movement and then energy like
energetic energetic the stability once
again because the Latin blood in me and
I decided to take all these values and
by the way loudness and tempo are some
other features I didn't mention before
but they are here and I just decided to
okay one loudness plus tempo plus energy
times hundred plus the stability times
hundred why the hundred because this
values energy and the stability are from
zero to one and the others are like
infinite battle I want two three
whatever whatever and I want to
normalize those values so this is my
fancy adventure for barriness however
there's something quite off here and I
realized after I finish according to
this the highest the value the less
duvall insan is but I'm calling this my
14s course so the option would be to
actually have this as a fraction but I
realized after I finished and I was like
whatever I don't want to redo anything
so sorry for that that's the sad face so
remember the high
the value the less for in the Sun East
and the lower the value the more for in
the Sun II but results yeah perfect once
again let's take a look at the blue and
we can see on the blue side we have this
cool this really large its main this
long tail on the blue side is stay to
the left meaning that most of the values
of my distribution they fall on the on
the lower end
so my values are really low so my sons
are more boring on the pink side we have
this really big peak almost at the
center of the plot meaning that her
value have a really high very nice core
meaning that remember her sons are less
boring than mine and to to make sure
this is right I calculate the mean of
the scores and we can see that on her
side is around 250 something and mine is
like 197 or so on so meaning that in s
and my playlist is more boring so she
won all of them but now is this one hers
or mine
I super basic learning approach like I
mentioned before my goal here was to
actually be make one system one model
able to predict either some belong to my
playlist or hares and for doing this I
usually stick regression because you are
error because it works is fast easy to
interpret and so on and the cool thing
is here that what I would like to
mention is how I train this we was a
really simple training but I just want
to mention it so first I use
cross-validation and then I use grid
search now I'm sure that a lot of you
know what is cross-validation which I
want explain but for those of you who do
not know what it's Chris earth it is
simply a mate an algorithm but it's used
for finding the best hyperparameters by
fitting the model yes I have it here
several times using combinations of them
sounds confusing but let's take a look
here on this map this dictionary that we
see the first code parameters are all
the possible parameters that I would
like to try to fit on my model to find
the best option on the first one the key
called loss is the loss function in this
case is logistic because we stick
then then one is penalty and in this
case I select to you elastic Ness which
is a mix of the l1 last regularization
all l2 rich regularization but then we
have all the alphas and the alphas is my
alpha value for the penalty and here I
have some values like a thousand hundred
ten and so on and so on and then the
number of iteration so after I have all
my possible parameters I'm going to use
my function grid search city grid search
cross-validation and using the SVD
classifier which is a linear model train
you see in stochastic gradient descent
then I'm going to send all my parameters
I'm going to train my system and this is
going to return the best the best model
and I have the notes here and that is
the Alpha of 0.001 and number of
iteration of a hundred but now the
results been 82% I feel is quite nice I
did to astonish number that means that
eight out of ten cases the model was
able to predict if the song is hers or
mine
and I decide to test that on some songs
that I didn't have on my playlist and on
my side I use one called a very
beginning by Mass Effect's a video game
and the answer was me and from here I
use one called off on the brain by
Rihanna have no idea how the song sounds
but I'm just going to assume that she
liked it and according to mr. logistic
regression she would like it now
this covenant similarities a
unsupervised learning approach and like
I mentioned before here my goal was to
cluster all my data and try to find
similarities within the cluster and I
divide this part into three different
sections first the number of closer how
many cluster I have to use what is the
best number of clusters then the
Clausura analysis and here i cross
through my dara you sink a medial it is
the the model i use and then how good is
the clustering for this part what i did
i delved inside my dataset using a lot
of manual labor and i just took a look
at all the songs to try to find it are
indeed similar but then i used model
lettuce saying other features however
I decided to remove energy because I
found out there was a high correlation
between energy and that's ability I
think and then I remove balance because
I wanted to keep it simple and was yell
and I just drop one of them to balance
goodbye now number of cluster how so for
finding out the best number of closer
are used two different techniques one of
the game is called a silhouette
coefficient and the gap statistic now I
will since I'm going to be using
mentioning the silhouette a couple of
time I'll give you guys a really brief
overview of what it is and according to
my notes the silhouette volume is some
measure of how similar an object is to
its own cluster this one cohesion
compared to the other closer separation
in other words these values are from
minus one until one so they the closest
the point is to the center the most
similar is to the other one the highest
is going to be the score on the other
hand if the value is kind of really
separate from the center of the closer
thing is going to be minus one and on
theory this means that this cluster
would be better in another cluster sorry
this data point would be better in
another cluster and these are the result
so for twin Dee's I just fit my model
using different values of K in this case
range from two until 10 and then I
calculate the average silhouette of each
one of the models and this is how it
looks like and here according to the
silhouette the best value is four with a
value of around 0.48 or 54 keep in mind
then with the gap if we look at the
elbow of the plot then we can see that
the value is also around three or five
so my last result the number I decided
to use was five why because even though
the silhouette was lower in five and one
of my goal was to actually study my
closer world
I need cluster and forests are really
ugly number so I just decided to go to
five because it's a really nice number
that everyone likes because also like
high five you know but okay now I have
my K let's close the poon magic number
stables these are the result of my
cluster don't worry I'm going to explain
what this means
and here is row it represents one of the
cluster and each column is a piece of
information about them and the first one
is the size and here we can see that the
smaller closer is the third one with 60
songs and the bigger one is closer for
with 143 the second and third column
they are the distal arity who are is the
dissimilarity well that is a molarity is
the distance between a data point and
the center of the cluster or the media
if we take a look at this really nice
plot that I have here we can see like
one of the blue point and the red one
the distance between the stars that is
similarity then we have the diameter and
the emitter is the maximal dissimilarity
in between two points of the same
cluster which it would be this blue that
is here on the left and this blue here
under right because they are the most
separate then we have separation a
separation is the minimal dissimilarity
between one data point and another one
of another cluster in this case would be
that blue that is there alone and one of
the greens may be the greens that is on
the top-left corner
but now according to these two these
numbers plus the tree form is the most
interesting one because it is the one
that the highest dissimilarity meaning
that all the points I cannot spread
around it is the one with the highest
diameter meaning that is kind of really
big cluster and the separation meaning
that is really alone on its own corner
we're going to see this later then here
is the silhouette of each one of the
data points each row here represents a
data point and they are grouped by
cluster and the first thing we see is
the average silhouette which is 0.4
which is good because I can mention
before the values are from minus 1 until
1 so a value of point 4 is quite okay
which and if we take a look on the right
side is the silhouette per cluster and
we have one cluster that is really
really bad with point 27 but we have one
that is really really cool with point 55
so what is the next step I have these ok
but I want to see my clusters so I
decided to select two of them to
actually go inside and see the data and
accelerate the third one because this
was the one with the most inter
steam father's in the table and the
fourth one because it is the one with
the greatest si silhouette value and
this is the result the next life's going
to be kind of ugly
it's going to be some of my songs that I
have in this cluster you can laugh or
you can make fun or yeah whatever so
here we go kloster for this is what we
have in cluster four so first we have 30
hate songs cheese's a t-38 of the Lord
of the Rings The Return of the King the
complete recording you know of course
the complete one album followed by this
I have interstellar the deluxe edition
12 songs thing I have 10 song from a
video game called Shutterfly I had never
played the game what the music is quite
cool and then we have I gain
interstellar but this is the non deluxe
edition meaning that I have some
duplicated here because they lost one
have some songs that I don't have in the
normal one and the rest is Mad Max final
fantasy Mass Effect deadmau5 video games
and more video game however there are
other songs that I didn't include in the
list but they include Kanye West
demurrer mr. robot muse The Hobbit and
so on so can you guys find any
similarity here can you guys find any
kind of pattern no okay no so the
summary is that I have a lot of
instrumental music in this cluster and
some of them they are from video games
and from movies but now let's go to the
third cluster and here is quite
different than the other it shows more
via variety for example the first two
albums are called the acoustic albums
and they are by above and beyond and
they are an electronic group of musician
and the acoustic albums they are
acoustic compilation of their song so to
hear this a lot of acoustic nest then we
have more Kanye West and these albums
note that the really Street Mall Kanye
West is more like really cool and
easygoing then we have more video games
and more interesting a lot more of more
Lord of the Rings and whatever but ok I
was here and there's a lot of variety
and I thought what if I closer this even
further to see if I could find some kind
of correlation stone some kind of
similarity in the cluster
so you know like a good inception I just
clustered this once again and this is
the silhouette and in this case it looks
a little bit more like worse than the
previous one because here the average is
still on point 29 and I have one cluster
that is really bad which point 10 and
another one that is really good with
point 47 but now let's take a look at
some of the content of this cluster and
the first one it has is really a mess it
has six off from an acoustic album wraps
on instrumentals music and some music
that are pop electronic and Spanish and
even some yes because I'm a classy and
sophisticated guy then then the second
closer we have a lot of acoustic then we
have lot of the reinvesting and
transistor but now to details these two
albums version and transistor they are
by the same guy so they follow the same
style and I was really happy to see them
in the same cluster and this opera Lord
of the Ring I believe it from the
standard edition I'm not sure if you
guys have watch it but there's one scene
when they are singing in the bar after
if they win every scene and you start
really happy they're seeing standing on
the table so that song is that one that
is here
meaning that in this cluster there is a
lot of happy song with a lot of
instruments Scioscia guitars and so on
but just trust me because I know how
this song sounds like and then the other
one the third one is really made is
kinda messy just wrap an electronic and
really nice combination and then close
therefore is the rest of the song from
music interstellar and Lord of the Rings
so in summary how good is the clustering
well I think my opinion is that the
cluster the model was able to capture
the essence of the clustering of the
music story and we saw that there is one
closer the hast a lot of instrumental
music so she a bit again a music there
is one that has a lot of easy listening
music like acoustic stones and there is
one I didn't talk about it but it has a
lot of rap and electronic music and the
other two are pure garbage so manly man
think about him but no the last part
beats watching the data because it's
always nice to see the data and here
I've been talking about
separation the similarity mumbo-jumbo
blahblah but I want to see this one okay
guys yeah so for doing this I had to use
two different techniques to lower the
dimensionality of my dataset because I
mean we are not super humans and we
cannot see in five dimensions at least I
don't so I used to really well-known
Kong techniques principal component
analysis and T distributed stochastic
neighbor and Verdean TS and E and E see
how it looks like really pretty out but
I would like you guys to focus on the
third cluster the one that I mentioned
before that was kind of crazy and we can
see that there is one point there in the
middle up there next to the second
cluster and there is one really small
here with all the red point and I
mentioned before that this cluster was
the one with the greatest diameter and
the greatest on the similarity and we
can see it here because there is one
pointer there under so the cluster is
really well spread around meaning that
those songs would be nice would be
better in some of the other cluster and
if we see the same dataset about this
time using PCA we can also observe the
same behavior in this case we can see
all those points a little closer that
are right in the middle of the plot and
there's even one that is kind of there
to the left so that this cluster is true
it really really really spread all
around and this is the PCA for the
second clustering I did and it doesn't
look that interesting except for the
fact that on the third cluster the one
that had rub an electronic music I have
five points that are there and four
points down and I have no idea what they
are because I didn't actually went to
see the songs but I'm just going to
assume that on top I have the electronic
one and on the bottom I have the rap
song because in an ideal world this
would be happening so conclusion of
everything music and data is an amazing
combination happy face and my music is
really boring is really varied and
instrumental interstellar soundtrack is
really amazing that's my opinion
my music are my girlfriend's is so
different that even a
she even machine-learning Canosa see
this really smart guy we're living in
the future and came media it was even
able to see the similarities some waste
in life right and then of course the
data looks pretty and that's it
same for your time I hope you guys
really enjoyed the presentation I think
I have like six minutes for question or
something
wish anybody questions oh geez hi
please take it easy slate how could I
not ask is your public playlist public
and your girlfriend's public as well
actually mine yeah silly me I don't have
to leave both hurt it's not I just
decided to hire because she was like
actually actually I wrote here like an
hour hour can you please say something
so I kept on the screen chill but she
was like no yeah she like SP remember
she was like dude don't go way too far
yeah if you could post your playlist
somewhere that would be cool perfect
yeah so in yep okay I'll posted in one
of these links somewhere yeah but I let
you know what she well somehow helpful
with the project she was calling me
because okay so it wasn't they I have to
explain this to her like hey baby you
know I do remember when you told me that
my music oh yeah why and then I was okay
I need your data you need my what
I need your data okay I need your
credentials purify but but babies for
research so you know it's at the end
okay for research here at the end it
were but I happened to come explain to
her because she has no idea what this
means
so sorry baby thank you you're welcome
[Laughter]
mister so obviously one can imagine that
this similarity or similarity of
playlists is like you know proper
relationship advice
this is just going on a limb here but
could you make maybe a dating service
based on data sets like this you just
say hey upload your Spotify playlist and
we're gonna find people I mean of course
I never thought of all that I'm
considering the fact that I work in a
dating company you know but I think it
could work
I mean like just maybe we can find like
to play it off to different users and
maybe we could even improve these
techniques because to be honest I did
this kind of not in a rush you know but
I just was just trying to do something
for fun but I'm guessing we could use
different clothes different techniques
for example like grid based clustering
or density based clustering oh we don't
even would have to touch clustering well
I like clustering so I would try this
clustering of course so I think that
would be a really really nice approach I
mean and as you guys saw there is indeed
some similarities found between the
cluster so maybe if I mix two of them
three different playlists I'm sure
something cool would come out hi I have
like one idea and told me tell me yeah
so maybe before you've done your
analysis and you did the pretty
clustering you should maybe look for
anomalies because what you described
pretty much in clustering our some of
the observations that are really far so
maybe if you did some anomaly searching
and you said okay this songs don't like
weird I would say yeah so you could
maybe just find really good clusters
just by having the the song sound this
songs like sorted out I mean that's a
really nice idea for example here I
mentioned that there's a candy West Sun
and even so this song is really
instrumental it doesn't really sound so
similar as the others so there are
indeed some anomalies I would really
like to do that so maybe I could just
pick up all the similar all the songs
that I classify as a anomaly and maybe
there's some similarity between them you
know that would be really cool the
second idea is as you have pretty much a
thing that says if it's it with suits
your playlists right so it suits your
type of music you could
use it to have new songs and just have
some manual classification so let's
let's say you have a new song and then
you say okay I like this one I don't
like this one so first of all you get
new music such profit and secondly you
can improve the models so its profit so
you know science and yeah
that's a really nice one I mean both of
them were realized but that one was
really cool
so saying for your tips thank you any
other questions okay thank you guys
you